un peu plus d'un an après la sortie de
fantômas andré hunebelle dans les
studios de billancourt met en scène la
suite de l'oeuvre de marcel à la phantom
as en revient on y retrouve jean marais
louis de funès jacques deen âme et
mylène demongeot hélène de bonjour qui
vous a envoyé cette très jolie robe
c'est un tonnage ses fantômes années
pourquoi bien parce que je savais que je
suis toujours photographes mais je tombe
dans les filets de fantômas et fantômas
depuis le premier film est amoureux de
moi et un moment donné il m'a
complètement à sa merci je dois lui
obéir complètement
et alors je reçois une invitation
brogniart mal à la comprendre
je dois me rendre ici en traîne pandore
jean marc et ses six enfants deux fils
être à ma poursuite
il arrive à me sauver c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont tous vont tous morts
sherazade oui en napoléon et à l'issue
du bal masqué 30 au mas a réussi à
attirer dans son antre le décor a coûté
500 mille francs
le commissaire jules fandor hélène
pour jean marais et louis de funès le
second comme le premier fantômas
représente une grande dépense physique
sur le plan athlétique est aussi
difficile que lors du premier saut je
crois qu à pont-de-roide
- j'ai eu à jouer avait la jouait la
truck et la peur de manquer en moto
d'ailleurs derrière jean baucou énorme
une moto j'ai passé mon charisme et à
l'étranger tu avais plus peur avec un
break avec moi je t'ai dit jeudi
mais c'est avec moi qui devrais ma peur
oui et il m'a dit ah ben non et après
mais la wii après par la suite commencé
dans leur âme et ses restes habillement
parachute tenu par le fonds du contrat
l'ongle est ce que vous espérez finir ce
film en est entier devient petit nous
récoltons géante hier pour la troisième
version affirmant